hello my name is Mary similar gah i'm
pleased to come and speak with you today
about chronic illness and how to
overcome it in my life I've experienced
both the good and the bad of chronic
illness and I have severe lung disease
now pulmonary fibrosis but all of my
life I was faced with a challenge of
very severe asthma from childhood on and
it just my lungs have just gotten
progressively worse over time in 2007 I
was diagnosed with pulmonary fibrosis
and after exhausting all the medications
and oxygen and everything I could with
my normal phone the pulmonologist I went
for an evaluation at johns hopkins
university medical center and that's
where i was diagnosed and at that time i
was told that the average pulmonary
vibrating patient lives five to seven
years post diagnosis and i'm now ten
years into that diagnosis so you can see
that I've made more progress than my
physicians expected me to but whenever I
get really bad news I am a realist and
I'm an optimist at the same time in that
I don't take bad news lightly however I
also don't take it in a fatalistic way I
want to overcome it and so I'm always
looking for that new challenge and my
personal life at the same time which is
like sort of the unfair you know when it
rains it for a story I began to
experience what i like to call my own
personal reign of terror and I lost the
people eight people closest to me in my
life in an eight-year period of time
while at the same time the lung disease
was getting worse and so it was just a
double whammy and I got so depressed at
one point because of complicated grief
that I came to the point of thinking
about suicide and actually apparently
having a psychotic break with reality my
neighbors heard me screaming one night
and they called the ambulance and that's
how I woke up in a psych ward in a
straitjacket strapped to a bed and when
I woke up in this
all white room I had absolutely no idea
where I was and I had been there for
nine days as I later found out this was
really an eye-opener for me I for the
eighth for the probably five years prior
to that I knew that I was seriously ill
with not only my lung disease but also
in my psyche I was seeing on maybe on
monday wednesday and friday i'd see my
psychiatrist and on tuesdays and
thursdays and sometimes saturday in the
ER as the pulmonologist that's too many
doctors in one's life and so i had to
find ways to cope with it and I really I
really came to that finding it out in a
really stark way in the site in the
hospital in the psychiatric treatment I
was fortunate enough to have a wonderful
psychiatrist and he came up with two
very creative ways for me to overcome my
what I we now know is an existential
vacuum I had no idea what I was going to
do with myself how was going to get
better where I was going to live but I
knew that I couldn't keep staying in my
home where there was no but nothing but
pictures of dead people on my walls and
nothing but oxygen tanks and medical
equipment said I had to plan a new life
when i said earlier that i had both the
good experience with the good and the
bad about chronic illness the good news
about this having chronic illness and
being forced to stop in what you're
doing get off that fast train of i have
to make more money you have to build a
bigger business i have to do this i have
to do that and coming and being stopped
in your dead dead in your tracks and
then really understanding at the pit of
your soul of what you need to do and
what's really important in life and it's
certainly not making money in building
bigger businesses it's being healthy
finding new people to love after you've
after loss and so he came up with two
creative ways for me to plan a new life
for myself he said why don't you think
since you're good at business why don't
you create a business plan for Mary to
point o make it like a real company with
a great board of directors and that's
and I said well no that's something I
can really wrap my head around because I
love to
create and develop incubate businesses
and the second thing he said is I'd like
for you to read this book man's search
for meaning and I laughed I miss laughed
in his face because I said I know I look
out Frankel I read his book in college I
met him I know all about his work and he
said well humor me read it again because
it never hurts to read it again and once
i had done both of those things I really
understood suffering at its core and and
I understood dr. Frankel's work in a way
that I hope most people don't have to
find out firsthand having experienced
the trauma that I experience and having
living and living with experience of the
trauma of my own chronic illness I was
forced to understand dr. Frankel's work
at a deeper level so that I could
uncover new meaning in my own life and
he was very very smart I mean obviously
one of the great geniuses of the world
and he taught us three ways that we can
create uncover meaning in our lives
first we can find a way to create
something will I do that with businesses
producing movies producing digital
content I always am create I'm always
creative the second way we can find that
is to experience someone to find a
person to love I've done that I knew
again and the third way we can do it is
to change our attitude towards suffering
or toward any circumstance and and you
don't have to suffer to find meaning but
there is meaning and suffering and that
I learned first hand and so I utilized
the wrinkles work in a in botha a
thoughtful way and a meaningful way to
uncover meaning and and I learned that I
could cope and I could get up every
single day and I still have to do that I
have to get up every single day and
realize that I'm not the person I was at
age 35 or 40 who wasn't sick and I have
to realign and adjust my new reality
everything
day ok today you're breathing pretty
good but you're still going to have to
spend two hours Mary taking medication
before you can start your work day so I
get up a little bit earlier and I plan
for whatever the circumstance is going
to be for example if I know that I'm
going out to dinner that night I don't
eat the whole day because when they eat
it lowers it makes my diaphragm go up
and because it squeezes up the billion
in it it shortens my vital capacity I
don't have as much air and I can't
breathe so I waited till the latest
possible moment in the day to even eat a
meal and those kind of things you do I
had to bring my office home because it
was too much it drank too much of my
energy to go to the office every day so
I brought my office home and so I work
from home now and I created I found
created a new business film company so I
can be a producer and work from my own
computer in my house so for the most
part so what I would advise anyone who's
overcoming chronic illness and facing a
possible terminal illness is adjust your
attitude in every moment moment by
moment minute by minute day by day year
by year and adjust to that new reality
and realize that though you will find is
dr. Frankel taught us meaningful moments
every step of the way I always tell
students when I'm talking about this
that they can also adapt my personal
mantra and that is if you live your life
from the inside out and not from the
outside in most of your day is going to
be wonderful anyway thank you for
listening